[Applauso]
innovarsi e rinnovarsi questo termine
non so a voi ma a me ricorda periodo un
po di qualche secolo fa
vedete la città di ale di piero della
francesca ne ricordo il rinascimento
momento in cui l'uomo ha ripresa
consapevolezza delle proprie
potenzialità e nato all'urbanistica è
nata l'attenzione su se stessa io da
piccola invece sono cresciuto a pane e
comodo 64 mio padre la mia famiglia mi
ha regalato questo computer voi
immaginate che la memoria di questo
computer e circa un quinto un quarto
delle sim che avete nel vostro cellulare
eppure i nemici giocavano e mi divertivo
con loro è utilizzato anche comodo 64
per per esempio per la tesina della
terza media ho presentato uno dei primi
una tesina stampata al computer ma nel
frattempo che io giocavo col computer
era influenzato dalla musica che
arrivavano dalle altre stanze brahms e
beethoven
era mia sorella mia sorella loredana che
la pecora bianca della famiglia pre
laurea musicista eccetera e non mi
rendevo conto di come questa musica
avrebbe influenzato la mia crescita
professionale e umana nel corso del
tempo sono dato liceo scientifico e ho
incontrato un professore professor
montemurlo anche qui chiedi materia
magari lo conosce abbastanza
anche qui io non mi sarei a un esame è
accorto di questo signore che spiega
biologia spiega l'anatomia spiega il dna
le renne a la geometria astronomica che
poi alla fine che cosa fa lascia tutto e
diventa un attore di teatro e fonda
un'associazione una compagnia di teatro
ma cos'hanno in comune mia sorella e poi
sull montemurlo il comodo 64
no non sono delle scimmie hanno ciò che
ci differenzia dalle scimmie il 2 per
cento del nostro patrimonio genetico
noi ci distinguiamo tra i nostri cugini
con quel 2 per cento che ci permette per
esempio di concepire l'umanesimo e la
cultura
ma questi personaggi famosi leibniz
cartesio pascal leonardo da vinci sono
famosissimi però se a ciascuno di voi vi
chiedessi loro chi sono alcuni direbbero
sono scienziati famosi leibniz ha
inventato il calcolo infinitesimale
pascal ha inventato le unità di misura
della pressione cartesio kg altri mi
risponderete ma come sono filosofi
cogito ergo sum
viviamo nel migliore dei mondi possibili
riceverai minutes
in verità non è così loro quando hanno
vissuto la loro epoca non erano o l'uno
o l'altro e hanno entrambe le cose
siamo noi che abbiamo messo le etichette
l'abbiamo differenziati tra di loro
abbiamo fatto quello che l'hai venice
diceva le monadi tanti oggetti tra di
loro che non si parlano assolutamente
impermeabili incomunicabili tra di loro
ognuno vede riflesso su se stesso il
mondo pensando che fosse l'unico mondo
possibile
quando invece non è così
un filosofo moderno piano dominici dice
che se vogliamo veramente rinascere
vogliamo veramente innovarci dobbiamo
rompere degli equilibri
dobbiamo spezzare le catene della
tradizione eh sì perché il cervello
umano non ragiona compartimento stagno
dato ragione a colle sinapsi con il
senza soluzione di continuità questo ha
portato un problema potrei dire ai
houston abbiamo un problema
l'italia è il primo paese al mondo
tristemente il primo paese al mondo per
l'analfabetismo funzionale cioè noi
sappiamo leggere e scrivere ma non
sappiamo usare questa competenza di
leggere e scrivere apriamo un testo
scolastico un libro un giornale
guardiamo la tv e non sappiamo crearci
un nostro senso critico il nostro
pensiero critico
non sappiamo estrapolare i concetti
fondamentali durante periodi di
candidatura di matera come capitale
europea della cultura 2019
alcune di noi hanno detto cerchiamo di
essere un po trasversali tra i
preconcetti
alcuni di noi hanno investito loro tempo
nell aiutare i bambini a essere soggetti
attivi nei confronti della tecnologia
del digitale
noi oggi diciamo tutti che i bambini
sono digitali nativi
sì è vero sono digitali nativi passivi
potrei dire come dice il cas call sullo
dei primi tv digitali bene un attimo
sappiamo usare lo strumento non sappiamo
programmarlo non sappiamo plasmarlo non
riusciamo a dire a lui che cosa deve
fare un giorno proprio da queste parti
abbiamo fatto una giornata così con
alcuni bambini per
spiegare come si può usare la
programmazione anche in età 6 e 7 anni
quindi parliamo di minimamente piccoli è
un preside michele venturelli di un
istituto comprensivo qui di matera ha
detto io questa cosa la voglio
in tutte le classi in tutti i bambini
del mio istituto per cui ci siamo messe
all'opera abbiamo cercato di dargli una
mano è un giorno è avvenuto questo
vediamo un po se riparte audio regia
le immagini sono comunque eloquenti
[Musica]
we are changin gava futures we are
making aver open futures in verità più
che lo slogan è stata una cosa in cui
credevamo e crediamo ancora formalmente
offerta fortemente cioè
l'autodeterminazione di un popolo di una
comunità cercare di creare un proprio
futuro che non sia predeterminato ma che
sia in continua costruzione il concetto
del co l'ing
e quindi prima il pensiero
computazionale poi il codice è entrato
addirittura a far parte della riforma
scolastica la riforma del piano
nazionale la scuola digitale oggi il co
ding si insegnerà in tutte le scuole
d'italia e tutti i club di coding che
sono nati in puglia basilicata sono nati
da matera abbiamo lanciato dei semi che
poi sono stati raccolti da tutti i
territori circostanti
questa cosa è piaciuta molto la
commissione europea che oltre a
giudicare matera per le infinite per
infiniti pregi per cui era candidata la
bellezza la storia il dossier di
candidatura in piccolino c'è anche
scritto il fatto che voi ne siate sulle
nuove generazioni nell'essere autori
attivi grazie al co ding del loro futuro
e altamente innovativa per una società e
quindi per una capitale europea della
cultura
quindi alla fine io mi chiederei una
cultura cos'è ok
questo è un episodio che secondo me
rende un po l'idea
noi siamo a casa cava un posto
meraviglioso è un bene monumentale voi
non so se sapete che in italia i beni
monumentali e culturali non si possono
fotografare e usare a scopo di lucro non
posso fare la fotografia del castello
mettono solo magliette vendere con la
maglietta e vietate a meno che il
soggetto proprietario del bene in questo
caso il comune non fa un elenco fanno fa
un elenco che normalmente si chiama un
elenco in open data cioè in una licenza
aperta affinché tutti possono
riutilizzare il comune di matera è uno
dei primi comuni in italia veglio
bendata lancia un bando e chiese anche
alle scuole di partecipare nell'usare
questo elenco di questi beni monumentali
e proprio istituto pascoli ha
partecipato a questo bando e ha vinto
dei bambini dieci anni hanno usato il co
ding per costruire un software inc weeks
sui beni monumentali di matera in
italiano e in inglese e hanno vinto un
bando battendo aziende e professionisti
l'ora dieci anni abbiamo sviluppato
delle competenze digitali applicate all
altro
stato del loro cervello cioè ai beni
culturali monumentali
oggi vi parlerò velocissimamente di te
lega una telegram è un sistema di
messaggistica come whatsapp voi prendete
vostro cellulare propagine la vostra
mano trattati di solito con i vostri
contatti
cercate un vostro amico e risate a
dialogare telecom permette però di fare
una cosa in più permette di costruire
degli autori dei box da robot con cui io
posso dialogare tramite delle parole
chiave cioè io gli chiedo accende la
luce lui accendo la luce piuttosto che
dove si trova il museo più vicino o un
passo del vangelo
mi sono divertito insieme ad altri a
costruire tanti tipi di questi automi in
maniera molto trasversale a concerto
classico informatico ma usando come
contenuto appunto alcune cose che
potrebbero essere utili per la società i
beni monumentali per esempio è i teatri
ei musei sono stati particolarmente
apprezzati dalla stampa nazionale e il
mibac il suggerisce di usare questo
strumento questo bot per trovare il
museo più vicino un giorno ho pensato un
attimo
io voglio impattare sulla scuola però io
voglio fare qualcosa che possa cambiare
un piccolo la didattica quotidiana
magari di un liceo ho chiamato non è
carissima amica una persona estero ss
limberti e ho detto mi controlli un
attimo velocemente il contenuto di
questa auto ma che ho creato
chiaramente mi ha sorriso dicendo cinque
minuti un po un po complesso riesca a
farlo perché parliamo della divina
commedia veniva commedia normalmente voi
la leggete maniera sequenziale terzine
sotto ci sono le parafrasi io leggo il
commento magari fatto mag un secolo e
mezzo farà qualcun altro più in luce di
noi ma anche qui i ragazzi che fanno
vengono giudicati dall'insegnante
rispetto a loro capacità di restituire
quello che hanno imparato rispetto alla
lezione frontale dell'insegnante
qui abbiamo gestibili di stabilizzato
tutto ho chiamato alcuni compagni di
viaggio perché la condivisione della
cultura della felicità è l'unica delle
delle poche cose che più la divido più
aumenta per cui ho chiamato finire
congedo che l'architetto di legami umani
professor pino giuliano che
il presidente dell'associazione dante
alighieri di matera la prof.ssa di sam
berti con la sua scuola è il professor
aprile e abbiamo costruito un format un
progetto
gli abbiamo dato un nome che si chiama
accendi dante perché accendi dante
questo è un estratto dell'automa di
telegram cui installatevi telegram
cercate divina commedia botta avrete
questo cercato una parola diomede e
riescono le terzine dove si parla di
diomede che succede però non c'è
nient'altro
c'è il testo asettico c'è soltanto
l'elenco di noi si trova con la terzina
noi destabilizzano il dio strutturiamo
completamente la didattica perché
obblighiamo gli insegnanti e la propria
classe a entrare in una chat i concetti
classici di spazio e tempo saltano io
non sono scrivania non c'ho le pareti
non ciò la mia autorevolezza dettata
dalla statale dire una scrivania al sì
me la devo conquistare sul campo in un
ambiente neutro che una chat e ragazzi
d'altro canto non possono più giocare
non possono più farsi selphy c'era
l'insegnante cia unapros line la chat si
focalizzano su una un aspetto soltanto
prendono un accanto tante sco e lo
studiano che utile studiare
didatticamente questa si chiama flipper
classe loro studiano prima l'argomento
poi ne parliamo in classe non ne
parliamo prima in classe e poi mi dice
quello che hai capito di quello che gli
ho detto si impegnano a cercare oggi su
internet cosa è pertinente con quella
terzina che loro hanno cercato quindi
emergono dei lati caratteriali dei
ragazzi che l'insegnante non mai
conosciuto l'arte la geografia la musica
bukowsky di de chirico altri testi
letterari
l'insegnante si trova di fronte una
persona che non avrebbe mai potuto
giudicare per quello che è come persona
ci incontriamo tutti è fedele come detto
prima aveva architetto di risorse umane
di legami tra le persone scrive su un
muro su un foglio di carta che gira
tutto intorno alla classe i pensieri dei
ragazzi perché hanno scelto quel quel
link su internet
ne approfittiamo facciamo educazione
all'uso della rete per cui diciamo
guarda che questo link su google il
primo che ho trovato non va bene
poi se dovessi trovare quel salto tipo
di approfondimento forse deve capire che
cosa vuol dire l'autorevolezza di quel
testo che trovi e così via
i ragazzi si accendono ma in verità si
accende anche dante per che riportiamo
in ottica moderna quello che il testo
dantesco e dandogli una nuova vita
questa cosa è piaciuta tantissimo alla
società tante le chiedi italiana c'è la
società che si occupa fondata da
giuseppe carducci della promozione della
lingua italiana è di tutto il mondo
dantesco per cui limitata a parte del
progetto adesso lo faremo in 40 dice in
tutta italia grazie anche la consulenza
scientifica arrivo la conclusione
chiedendovi più che altro una preghiera
che un suggerimento e barra preghiera
queste immagini sono prese dal film the
wall dei pink floyd dove l'educazione la
classica educazione trasferita dall alto
e i ragazzi non hanno una loro identità
sono quasi dei soldati se vogliamo non è
sempre così oggi per fortuna italia ci
sono scuole d'eccellenza come majorana
di brindisi ma tantissima le scuole
anche non così famose che cercano di
innovarsi e rinnovare da capo
il metodo dell'educazione ma perdonatemi
nella stragrande maggioranza dei casi
vige ancora questo l'imbuto di
norimberga cioè la concezione che la
conoscenza è come se fosse un fluido che
va trasferito dall'alto di un muto in un
secchio vuoto che il cervello
dell'alunno ecco io vi lascio con questa
preghiera non concepiamo l'educazione e
l'istruzione come riempire un secchio
ma come accendere dei fuochi grazie
[Applauso]